- This map shows the flu is going crazy.
Levels are really high in
most of the country right now.
RSV and covid are also circulating,
setting up a potential tripledemic.
- [Narrator] This season's triple threat
is taking a toll both
on patients and staff.
- Now the WHO and CDC are worried
about a potential surge
in the cases of strep
and some public health experts say
that the culprit could be the flu.
Here's why.
The flu is a virus
and it can leave you more vulnerable
to getting bacterial infections,
like with Streptococcus bacteria,
which causes strep.
There are three main reasons for that.
First, flu makes it easier
for bacteria to infect you.
It damages little hairlike
structures called cilia
that line the respiratory tract.
- The cilia can't clean out,
or wash out the lungs like they're used to
and the bacteria can get stuck down there
and then they can replicate
and cause more problems.
- [Daniela] Second, flu
infections also cause inflammation
that starts to break apart the tight links
between cells and the lining of our lungs,
which acts as a protective barrier.
- That allow bugs to come through,
almost like a little bug highway.
- [Daniela] Third, the flu
strains the immune system.
So, if strep bacteria
managed to infect you
the immune system has a
harder time fighting them off.
- Every time there's a flu season
there's gonna be a lot more incidents
of strep secondary infections.
- [Daniela] Those can lead to
complications like pneumoniae
or in very rare cases
the toxic shock syndrome
that doctors are seeing in kids.
Look at all this red and purple.
This flu season is particularly bad.
That's partly because of the pandemic.
Masking, social distancing
and working remotely
protected us against covid,
but those precautions also kept us
from getting sick generally.
- And there isn't a lot
of population immunity
against many infections.
- [Daniela] So viruses
like RSV and the flu
can now get around more easily.
The cases of strep are coming
at an unusual time of
year from what's expected.
It's a trend we're seeing with RSV
and other infectious diseases
since the lockdowns ended.
Flu cases are spiking really quickly
and that's what might be leaving us
more vulnerable to strep.
- There's gonna be so many more cases
of strep causing serious infection.
- Who is most at risk?
Well, that depends on the kind of strep.
- The number of children who have died
from strep A across the UK since September
has now risen to 19.
- [Daniela] And the CDC is also looking
at a possible spike in strep
A related complications
in kids in the US.
- Children, particularly smaller children,
have all kinds of
different strains of strep
in their nose and throat every single day
that never causes a problem.
- Their immune system can
typically fight them off,
but things are more complicated right now
thanks to surges in flu and
lower level population immunity.
Plus, it's possible that
strep A could be changing too,
to become more invasive.
All that together is
why we might be seeing
a potential increase in
serious strep A cases
and why it's getting a lot of attention.
But it's a different family of strep
that typically causes the most problems.
It's called Streptococcus pneumoniae.
- The vast majority of flu seasons
influenza isn't actually
the source of death.
It's the infection caused
by the strep pneumoniae
and the pneumoniae associated with that.
- Doctors recommend
that people 65 and over
get a vaccine against strep pneumoniae
to prevent complications from flu.
They say the same is true for people
with compromised immune systems,
heart disease or chronic lung conditions.
But for most people
strep doesn't cause
life-threatening issues.
- It's really rare to
have bad consequences
from strep as opposed to influenza,
which kills 35,000 to
70,000 people a year.
- That's why Peter and David
said it was really important
to get our flu shots,
especially this year.
And right now vaccination rates
for flu are pretty low.
So, how do we prevent all this?
It's simple.
Wash your hands, wear a
mask, and get your flu shot.
And if you do end up
testing positive for strep,
antibiotics work really well.
Remember, regardless of what you have,
stay home so you don't pass it on.
Infections aren't mutually exclusive.
Just because you just got over one illness
doesn't mean you're immune to others.
(gentle violin music)